[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin guten Abend Christin otto
hat später eine extra Portion
Wintersport für uns Showdown in
Bischofshofen guten Abend dann blicken
wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
Themen zwei Parteitreffen in bewegten
Zeiten dabei sieht sich die FDP mit
recht weiter in der Regierung und die
CSU erneuert ihre
nach
Neuwahlen scharfe Attacke unter Rivalen
nach Ansicht von US-Präsident Biden
würde Donald Trump die Demokratie opfern
um wieder an die Macht zu
kommen und ganz hat's nicht gereicht im
entscheidenden springen der vier
chancenournee muss Andreas Wellinger dem
Japaner kobiashi den Vortritt
lassen ein politisch bedeutsames Jahr
ist angebrochen für alle Parteien ist es
darum entsprechend wichtig ihr Profil zu
schärfen auch zu aktuellen Themen wie
etwa die aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
bauernproteste die FDP ist zum
Dreikönigstreffen zusammengekommen die
CSU trifft sich gerade zur
jahresauftaktklausur es geht darum sich
für ein Jahr voller Wahlen aufzustellen
am 9 juni wird das Europäische Parlament
gewählt und im zweiten Halbjahr da
geht's dann um mehrere Landtage am 1
September in Sachsen und Thüringen am 22
September dann in Brandenburg wie die
FDP in dieses Wahljahr startet hat Sven
Klass
beobachtet auf ihr ruht besonders viel
Hoffnung fast schon euphorisch feiern
die FDPler beim Dreikönigstreffen ihre
Spitzenkandidatin für die Europawahl die
kämpfen
will zeigen wir dem Jahr 2024 es ist
nicht das Jahr der Nationalisten es ist
das Jahr der Demokraten es ist das Jahr
der freiheitsliebende es ist das Jahr
der euräerin und Europäer Optimismus
verbreiten sich selbst Mut machen das
wollen sie hier wohl wissen dass viele
im Land nicht einverstanden sind mit
ihrer Politik in der Ampel Protest
drinnen von
Globalisierungskritikern draußen von
Landwirten die weiterfdern alle
geplanten Kürzungen zurückzunehmen
parteisf Lindner reagiert gerade eine
europäisch und national so hoch
subventionierte
Branche wird sich nicht jedes
konsolidierungsbeitrags
denn die Haushaltslage ist angesichts
vieler Krisen bekanntermaßen schlecht
die Wirtschaft obendrein schwer
angeschlagen die wieder in Schwung
bringen gibt die FDP als Kernaufgabe für
2024 aus unter anderem durch steuerliche
Anreize und weniger Bürokratie die
Schuldenbremse für Vorhaben der
ampelpartner auszusetzen lehnt Lindner
ab und verteidigt die bisherige
Regierungspolitik die Bundesregierung
handelt sie ist nicht
fehlerfrei wer
das aber wir entscheiden mehr richtig
als falsch denn sonst würde die FDP
dieser Regierung nicht angehören nicht
alle hier sehen das so vielen wäre ein
ampelaustritt lieber und doch gibt es am
Ende auch für den Parteichef Beifall und
die Hoffnung dass die FDP in den
Wählerumfragen wieder zulegt bundesweit
liegt sie derzeit um 5% in den
ostdeutschen Ländern in denen 2024
gewählt wird g
darunter jetzt zur der CSU Landesgruppe
weil die Zustimmung für die Ampel
dramatisch schwindet stellt sich die
Union auf mögliche Neuwahlen ein
interessant dabei auch die Frage nach
einer möglichen Kanzlerkandidatur
schließlich gilt csuchef Söder als
möglicher Favorit wie er sich
positionierte und was in klosteron noch
wichtig war dazu Alexander
pouh kurz vor Beginn der CSU Klausur im
bayerischen Kloster Seon protestieren
Landwirte gegen die Politik der
Bundesregierung das D die Bauern an
ihrem Protest festhalten findet CSU
landesgruppenchef Alexander Dobrind
richtig die Blockade der Fähre von
Wirtschaftsminister Robert habbeck aber
verurteilt er scharf das was wir da
gesehen haben am an der Fähre des eine
Entgleisung
die unmöglich
ist die so nicht stattfinden darf die
CSU beschreibt ein polarisiertes Land
und sieht die Schuld dafür bei der
Bundes Reg die Ampel habe Deutschland in
Unruhe gebracht Rekordschulden
angekündigte Steuererhöhungen die
ungelöste Migrationsfrage dazu der
Streit innerhalb der Regierungsparteien
noch nie gab es eine Regierung die so
wenig Vertrauen bei der Bevölkerung
hatte noch nie gab es eine Koalition die
so wenig Vertrauen zueinander hatte
Söder und Dobrind stellen die Union
heute als Gegenentwurf zur Ampel da
weite Teile der Migrationspolitik oder
das Bürgergeld wollen sie
zurücknehmen wir wollen das
fehlgeleitete
Bürgergeld abschaffen und dafür den
Menschen Möglichkeiten bieten dass sich
Arbeit mehr lohnt
Steuerfreiheit für mehr Arbeit schaffen
die CSU drängt auf Neuwahlen mit Blick
auf die kfrage rätt Söder zu Geduld er
lässt aber durchblicken wen er 2025 als
Kanzlerkandidat sieht bis auf weiteres
die derzeitige Favoritenrolle ist ja
ganz klar benannt bei fri z morgen
empfangen die CSU Abgeordneten unter
anderem den sächsischen
Ministerpräsidenten Kretschmer das Thema
die diesjährigen Landtagswahlen in
Ostdeutschland
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister
östemier hat davor gewarnt dass die
bauernproteste unterwandert werden durch
Leute von ganz rechts außen mit
umsturzfantasien das sagte der grüne
Politiker im ZDF der Bauernverband rief
die Teilnehmer der ab Montag geplanten
Protestwoche zur Mäßigung auf es dürfe
etwa keine persönlichen Anfeindungen
geben in den USA wird das Oberste
Gericht am 8 februar über Donald Trumps
Teilnahme an den republikanischen
Vorwahlen in Colorado verhandeln der
US-Staat hatte ihn davon ausgeschlossen
Grund ist Trumps Rolle beim Sturm auf
das Kapitol auf den Tag genau vor drei
Jahren drangen radikale trumpanhänger
gewaltsam in den US-Kongress ein
versuchten die Bestätigung des Wahl es
von Joe Biden zu verhindern dazu
angestachelt hatte eben Donald Trump
auch deshalb griff der US-Präsident ihn
jetzt bei seinem wahlkampfauftagt scharf
an Elm Tison aus
Washington wenn eine Botschaft ankommen
soll muss nicht nur das Gesagte passen
sondern auch die Kulisse Joe Biden
wählte Valley Forge Ort des winterlagers
von George Washington
17777 aus verzweifelter Lage führte er
damals seine Armee am Ende siegreich
gegen die Truppen des englischen Königs
eines Tyrannen und nun so beiden wolle
sich Donald Trump zum König
machen Donald Trumps Wahlkampf ist
besessen von der Vergangenheit nicht der
Zukunft er will unsere Demokratie Opfern
und sich selbst
ermächtigen wir wissen alle wer Donald
Trump ist wir müssen die Frage
beantworten wer wir sind das steht auf
dem Spiel wer sind
[Applaus]
wir schon einmal habe Trump zum Umsturz
aufgestachelt nun befeuere er weiter die
wahllüge nenne die Aufständischen
Patrioten nach Umfragen glaubt ein
Viertel der Amerikaner dass das FBI
hinter dem Sturm aufs Kapitol steckte
und Trump so beiden sähe nun weiter
Hass er nennt alle die gegen ihn sind
Ungeziefer er sagt Amerikas Blut werde
von Zuwanderern vergiftet das ist exakt
die gleiche Sprache wie eins den Nazi
Deutschland nur Stunden nach beidens
Auftritt macht Trump sich in Iowa lustig
über ihn er sagt ich se eine Bedrohung
für die
Demokratie Demokratie er konnte das Wort
nicht einmal
lesen Trump behauptet die wahre
Bedrohung für die Demokratie sei beiden
die Wähler müssen nun entscheiden
welcher Botschaft sie
glauben die Botschaft von US
Außenminister blinken ist klar er drängt
auf eine Lösung im Gazakrieg und reiß
dafür wieder durch den Nahen Osten seine
erste Station führte aber erst einmal zu
einem schwierigen Partner zum türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan schwierig weil er
mit Hamas sympathisiert und gegen Israel
polemisiert trotzdem sieht blinken in
ihm einen sehr wichtigen Vermittler Anna
Feist ein Foto das war's statt großer
Liveberichterstattung wie sonst in der
Türkei bei einem Besuch der Amerikaner
üblich ist Erdogan heute nicht bereit
für große Gesten
seine Sympathien stehen fest
eindrucksvoll demonstrierte die
türkische Regierung bei einer Demo vor
wenigen Tagen mit
250.000 Teilnehmern mitten im
touristischen Zentrum Istanbuls dass sie
fest an der Seite der Palästinenser
stehen und damit gegen Israel und dessen
hauptverbündeten die USA seit Wochen
schon feindet Erdogan den israelischen
Ministerpräsidenten Netanyahu offen an
ist das was dieser Netanyahu tut weniger
als das was Hitler t
das ist es
nicht Israel sei ein Kriegsverbrecher
die in der EU als Terrororganisation
eingestufte Hamas dagegen sei eine
Befreiungsorganisation
öffentlichkeitswirksam inszeniert sich
Erdogan als Beschützer der Unterdrückten
in der muslimischen Welt und der Westen
nimmt das hin denn Erdogan habe einen
Plan sagt Politikwissenschaftler Ülgen
der türkische Präsident wolle die
palästinensischen Konfliktparteien
fatach und Hamas versöhnen und so zum
Friedenshüter in einem nachkriegsgaser
werden wenn das klappt dann wäre das für
den Westen insbesondere für die USA
durchaus positiv denn wenn die Türkei
diese Rolle nicht übernimmt dann würde
es der Iran tun oder dieses Momentum
dieser sehr kritischen Annährung könnte
verpuffen Erdogan könnte so zu einer
Schlüsselfigur werden für ein
nachhaltigen Frieden in Nahost das wohl
der Grund warum der amerikanische
Außenminister blinken seine
nahostdplomat ausgerechnet in der Türkei
gestartet hat und warum er die
Missachtung des türkischen Präsidenten
einfach
weglächelt jeder Tag ohne Lösung
verschlimmert die Situation in Nahost
aus dem Libanon hat die terrormiliz
Hisbollah den Norden Israels angegriffen
mit mindestens 40 Raketen laut Hisbollah
eine Reaktion auf die Tötung des Hamas
offiziellen al aururi im Libanon am
Dienstag und im Gazastreifen da spitzt
sich die humanitäre Situation zu die UNO
nennt den Küstenstreifen größtenteils
unbewohnbar über das Leben in Trümmern
Michael
bberunge früher war das mal ein ganz
normaler Platz in raffach jetzt ist ein
großer Markt für Flüchtlinge daraus
geworden trotz der schwierigen
Versorgungslage gibt es hier viele
Lebensmittel und andere Waren zu kaufen
und doch ist das alles für Flüchtlinge
wie Salem suuka
unerreichbar sechs Schäkel für eine Tüte
Chips fragt ungläubig die kostet sonst
einen Schäkel ja schimpft Händler
Abdullah alo zurück das war der Preis
vor dem
Krieg der Grund ist sie erheben mehr
Zölle als vor dem Krieg schon davor
haben wir unter den Zöllen gelitten aber
heute noch mehr als
früher sie das sind die Beamten der
Hamas die hier auf alles die Hand halten
ohne selbstlöhne auszuzahlen kaum jemand
hat noch
Arbeit im Norden Autozubehör verkauft
jetzt lebt er im Zelt mit seiner Familie
und weiß nicht wie er die ernähren
soll das Arbeitsleben ist völlig zum
Erliegen gekommen wir leben
ausschließlich von der Hilfe anderer
Menschen wir fühlen uns gedemütigt was
sollen wir nur tun neben dem Angebot des
Marktes sollten eigentlich mehr
Hilfslieferungen die Menschen erreichen
un und Israel weisen sich gegenseitig
die Schuld zu andererseits landen
ungüter wie dieser Energieriegel auf dem
freien Markt obwohl nicht Verkauf
bestimmt die Menschen brauchen etwas
anderes selbst wenn es Brot gibt wo ist
das Geld um es zu kaufen wo ist der Reis
die Menschen haben Hunger Brot für Gaza
für die meisten ein unbezahlbarer Traum
bei einem russischen Raketenangriff auf
die Stadt pokrowsk sind nach
ukrainischen Angaben elf Menschen ums
Leben gekommen unter den Toten sein auch
fünf Kinder zuvor hatte die Ukraine
mitgeteilt eine russische
Kommandozentrale auf de Militär
Flugplatz Saki auf der Krim zerstört zu
haben Russland wiederum meldete den
Abschuss von vier ukrainischen Raketen
auf der völkerrechtswidrig annektierten
Halbinsel nach Südamerika bolivien hat
den größten kokainpfund seiner
Geschichte gemeldet nach Angaben des
Innenministeriums wurden mehr als 8
Tonnen beschlagnahmt das entspricht
einem Straßenverkaufswert von fast 500
Millionen Euro schon vor einer Woche
wurden die Drogen versteckt Holzplatten
in einem Lkw in den Anden entdeckt die
Lieferung sollte offenbar in die
Niederlande gehen nach UN-Angaben ist
Bolivien der weltweit drittgrößte
Produzent von Kokain nach Kolumbien und
Peru 5 Tage nach dem schweren Erdbeben
in Japan ist die Zahl der Toten auf
mindestens 126 gestiegen mehr als 200
Menschen werden laut Behörden weiter
vermisst noch immer suchen
Rettungskräfte nach Überlebenden kaputte
Straßen Regen und hunderte Erdrutsche
behindern allerdings ihre Arbeit in die
betroffenen Gebiete können deshalb auch
nur schwer Hilfsgüter geliefert werden
am Neujahrstag hatte ein Beben der
Stärke 7,6 die Westküste Japans
erschüttert in den Hochwassergebieten in
Deutschland steigen die Pegelstände
nicht mehr das ist eine gute Nachricht
viel Orts lässt der Regen nach oder hat
aufgehört aber die Wasserstände die
fallen nur langsam sagen die Behörden
vor allem in Niedersachsen sind viele
Regionen betroffen für Mieter und
Hausbesitzer stellt sich die Frage wer
die Schäden bezahlt in der Politik gibt
es Stimmen die eine Pflichtversicherung
für Elementarschäden fordern Clemens
Altmann die Straßen in Liliental stehen
unter Wasser nur langsam kehren die
Bewohner zurück in ihre Häuser deiner
kunika wendel begutachtet Ihr Wohnzimmer
die Schäden sind
immens was ich habe versucht aufzubauen
und das ist einfach mal weg in eine
Nacht weg das ist schlimm genug und ich
sehe noch nicht ausreichend
Möglichkeiten dass das Unterstüzung
kommt Unterstützung Entschädigung
finanzielle Hilfe für den Wiederaufbau
die Chefs der 16 Bundesländer sind sich
einig der Staat kann nicht ständig für
alle Schäden bei Naturkatastrophen
aufkommen sie wollen eine elementar
Pflichtversicherung doch dafür braucht
der Staat einen
Rechtfertigungsgrund bei
Elementarschäden an gebäen könnte die
refertigung darin liegen Steuerzahler
entlastet wird denn bislang ist es
häufig die Allgemeinheit die für
Unwetterschäden aufkommt wenn
Versicherungen fehlen in Niedersachsen
haben nur etwa ein Drittel der
Betroffenen eine
Elementarversicherung viel zu wenige
sagen die Versicherer sie wollen sie
allerdings nicht zur Pflicht machen wir
würden nicht die Bürger verpflichten
sondern uns als Branche verpflichten
jeden wohngebäudebesitzer eine
Elementarversicherung anzubieten und der
kann dann entscheiden ob er das Angebot
annimmt oder eben nicht aber wenn er es
nicht annimmt heißt das auch dass es
keine staatlichen Hilfen mehr geben wird
deiner kunik wendel schätzt den Schaden
auf eine sechsstellige Summe Möbel und
anderes Inventar sind versichert aber
ihr fehlt der
elementarversicherungsschutz für das
Gebäude am Dreikönigstag heute der
traditionelle Empfang der sternsänger im
Schloss belv Bundespräsident Steinmeier
und seine Frau begrüßten eine Delegation
von Jungen und Mädchen in diesem Jahr
aus dem um Limburg die Sternsinger
sammeln Spenden für Kinder die weltweit
in Not sind Steinmeier würdigte ihr
Engagement und sagte ihr Segen und ihre
Botschaft seinen im Hinblick auf Krieg
in Europa und viele andere Katastrophen
wichtiger denn
je
haarscharf an der Katastrophe
vorbeigeschrammt sind 171 Passagiere der
US Fluggesellschaft Alaska Airlines
gerade in Oregon gestartet durften sie
ihren Augen nicht getraut haben als
plötzlich ein
kabinenteilabriss einen großen Knall
habe es gegeben berichten sie ein junger
Mann der nahe am aufgerissenen Loch saß
erlitt beim Druckabfall Prellungen die
Boeing 7379 Max konnte aber umdrehen und
sicher landen jetzt will Alaska Airlines
all seine Maschinen vom selben Typ erst
einmal genau
prüfen so jetzt zum Wintersport vier
schanzenournee es hat am Ende nicht ganz
gereicht für Andreas Wellinger trotzdem
ein toller Erfolg 22 Jahre nach dem
Triumph von Sven Hanner Wald beendet
Andreas Wellinger die Tournee als
hervorragender zweiter überragend der
Japaner rioyo Kobayashi der zum dritten
Mal Gesamtsieger wird beim spannenden
Abschluss in
Bischofshofen Bischofshofen gilt als
heimschance für den Wahl Salzburger
Andreas Wellinger 2,5 m muss er aufholen
auf Kobayashi erster Durchgang 132 m
dann Hektik beim Japaner und seinen
Technikern warum nach dem Sprung
Kobayashi nutzt die besseren Winde 15
Minuten nach Wellinger springt 137 m
japanische Freude und der Japaner zeigt
Aufregung kam nur auf weil er seine Ski
vergessen hatte er bleibt cool zweiter
Durchgang Wellinger liegt jetzt schon
10,5 m hinter dem Japaner er kommt als
Jäger nun auch auf 137 m was schafft
Kobayashi es wird der kürflug eines
Japaners keine Dramatik am Dreikönigstag
Kobayashi springt souverän 139 m und ein
Österreicher jubelt auch Stefan Kraft
holt den Tagessieg aber Kobayashi
gewinnt zum dritten Mal die
vierchancenournee mit viermal Platz 2
bei vier
Springen zweiter Tag beim Biathlon
Weltcup in Oberhof aber diesmal ohne
Podestplätze für die deutschen Johannes
kühn war als Achter der beste in der
Verfolgung beim Tagessieger von gestern
lief trotz glänzender Ausgangsposition
gar nicht
rund Benedikt doll stand die
Enttäuschung ins Gesicht geschrieben der
sprintsieger von gestern verschoss
gleich im ersten siegendanschlag mit
drei Strafrunden alle Siegchancen und
landete schließlich auf Rang 12 es hat
nicht viel mit Pech zu tun es war
einfach maximale Dummheit der Norweger R
strömsem freute sich über seinen ersten
Weltcupsieg vor seinen Landsmännern
lagreit und Doris gfstal bei den Frauen
rettete sich Sprint zweite Franziska
Preu auf dem steilen birgsteig mit
schweren Beinen und stumpfen Brettern
auf Rang 7 dann hat mal ab der ersten
Runde schon bisschen so die Körner
gezogen oder mehr als sie hab und ja es
war dann schon Kampf auf der Strecke die
schnellsten am Grenzadler kamen aus
Frankreich Julia Simon sicherte sich
ihren ersten Saisonsieg vor Justine
bresas
BCH super glücklich über ihren ersten
Podestplatz in diesem Winter ist
schilangläuferin Katharina hennich auf
der vorletzten Etappe der Tour dei
belegt sie in Waldi femme im massenstad
über 15 km Platz 3 hinter den
Schwedinnen Lin SW und Frieda Carlsson
Teamkollegin Victoria KL wurde
sie
einen wahren tennisgrimie gab es in
Sydney beim United Cup mit Happy End für
das deutsche Team zuerst gewann Angeli
Kerbe ihr Spiel danach verlor Alexander
SF sein Einzel die Entscheidung gegen
Australien fiel im Mix Doppel indem sich
das Duo SF Laura sigemund erneut
durchsetzte mit 7:6 6:7 und
unglaublichen 15:13 im Match taibrrig
2:2 in der Nacht Finalgegner morgen
Polen hoffentlich dann
ausgeschlafen gut ein Jahr nach dem Tod
von P trauert Brasilien um seine
Fußballlegende Mario sagallo der gestern
im Alter von 92 Jahren gestorben ist
sagallo war der erste der als Trainer
und Spieler Weltmeister wurde zweimal an
der Seite von pel hier sein Treffer zum
4:1 im wm-fale 58 gegen Schweden 1970
führte er die celesao in Mexiko als
Trainer zum dritten
WM-Titel und eine super gute Einstimmung
auf die handballem hier in Deutschland
gibt's im ell Sportstudio von 23:30 Uhr
an Juri Knorr ist da ein Shootingstar
danke schön Christin wir hätten noch ein
schicke Bilder vom größten
eisskulpturenfest der Welt in der
nordchinesischen Stadt Harbin
präsentieren sie einen Winter Wonderland
der Superlative auf einer Fläche von
über 600.000 Quadrat und zum Leben
erwacht die suriale Stadt aus Eis vor
allem am Abend dann erstrahlen all die
eiskalten Kunstwerke und weil es am Tage
auch nicht wärmer als bibbrige -25°
werden haben die Menschen dann auch ein
bisschen länger was
davon ja ganz so kalt wird's bei uns
nicht aber kälter Einzelheiten gleich
mit Christa Orben das heutejournal heute
um 23:15 Uhr mit Christian sias noch
einen schönen Samstagabend für Sie und
bis morgen wenn Sie
[Musik]
mögen
guten Abend die Frostluft aus Nordosten
ist unterwegs und ab morgen setzt sie
sich auch bis in die Mitte und in den
Süden durch so ist es heute Nacht nur
noch im Südwesten frostfrei bei 1 bis 4°
in der okmark sinken die Werte schon auf
-6° und es kann dann glatt werden auch
da wo schneem mit im Spiel ist in der
Mitte Schneid es heute Nacht leicht im
Süden kräftig oberhalb von 400 bis 600 m
kommen 5 bis örtlich über 10 cm Schnee
zusammen von Norden her wird es aber
jetzt immer trocken und so gibt es
morgen in der Nordhälfte Deutschlands
einen trockenen Tag zwar ist es meist
bewölkt an der Nordsee scheint aber auch
länger die Sonne von der ostseehe her
gibt's immer wieder kräftige
Schneeschauer nach Mecklenburg vorpommen
hinein das ist der Lake Effekt durch den
lebhaften und kalten Nordostwind zwar
schneit es dann anfangs auch in der
Mitte noch etwas der Fokus liegt aber im
Süden da kommen rund um die Alpen noch
mal um die 10 cm Neuschnee zusammen und
im Tagesverlauf geht dann auch der
letzte Regen in Schnee über der bleibt
in höheren lag dann auch liegen bei 0
bis 4° im Westen und im Süden Dauerfrost
gibt's im Norden und im Osten bei 0 bis
-4° und Dauerfrost am Tag für alle gibt
dann zu Beginn der neuen Woche es
erwarten uns dann zwar sehr kalte aber
auch viel sonnigere Wintertage tschüss